[Applaudissements]
il boit pas il boit pas gorbatchev je
buvais seulement de la bière un petit
peu de bière non
bio ah non je bois tout à tous
alors
vous savez si ce n'est fini avec
l'hélico pour l'alcool nourricier
en tous les cas mikhaïl gorbatchev merci
beaucoup d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle pour la sortie de votre livre
dialogue pour la paix entretien avec dai
saku ikeda qui paraît aux éditions du
rocher vous savez comment on fait
voilà et c'est une belle leçon pour tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas le faire
merci bien alors vous êtes le dernier
président de l'urss
prix nobel de la paix en 1990 pour votre
contribution essentielle à la fin de la
guerre froide
vous êtes à la tête du parti social
démocrate qui soutiendra
sa marche pas
son apparaît et disparaît alors ça va
pas du tout il faut que c'est faux que
c'est pas une grève au moins
[Rires]
vous voulez être président de chippis
pour le moment ça va donc vous êtes le
dernier président de l'urss prix nobel
de la paix 1990 pour votre contribution
essentielle à la fin de la guerre froide
vous êtes à la tête du parti social
démocrate qui soutiendra vladimir
poutine pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle rostov n'est donnée vous
l'avez eu du tout juste bien alors il y
a dix ans presque jour pour jour
disparaissait l'union soviétique et
c'est vraiment extraordinaire et je vous
en remercie encore de vous avoir avec
nous ce soir mais wright gorbatchev
alors effectivement quand vous êtes
arrivé au pouvoir en urss vous des
mortiers énormément avec la
gérontocratie qui régnait alors au
kremlin et vous imposer un new look au
pouvoir en urss parce que d'abord vous
êtes capable de sourire
ensuite vous avez ce qui est rare là bas
quand même se souvenir ensuite vous
aviez une allure moderne et votre épouse
notre cher raïssa était une véritable
first lady est ce que c'était votre
nature profonde où c'était une stratégie
politique
au créneau sur notre allemand non non
c'est tout à fait naturel si vous venez
tout seul pourtant vous aviez gravi tous
les échelons du parti communiste
soviétique avec des gens qui étaient pas
drôle du tout et vous les avez supporté
pendant des années avec cette nature là
vous savez y ait beaucoup de gens qui
étaient très sympathiques et guy d'abord
il y avait des niches haut niveau tout
seul je n'aurais plus rien faire
en ce moment là j'aurais juste faire
faire ce petit geste
ils sont attirés moi j'ai un peu préparé
l'émission aujourd'hui et donc j'ai une
question à poser comme je suis j'ai un
prénom j'ai prénom russe donc j'ai une
question à vous poser
mag oublia patcher la vaste wass
paloschi est ce que je peux vous faire
enduisez à la russe
et ça veut dire commencer c'est quoi le
baiser à la russe
la russie
est
ce les robots et à quoi je m'attendais à
une proposition de ce genre sur mac ou
shetty
nico mas biblia patcher la vaste et
basse parce que moi je peux faire une
bise à la richesse et l'accolade la tête
à des civils
bien
catherine car
alors il règne 20e quand vous arrivez au
pouvoir vous arrivez avec trois nouveaux
concept la pérestroïka la glace notes et
la nouvelle pensée diplomatique nouvelle
pensée diplomatique c'est ralentir la
course aux armements qui était intenable
pour un pays comme l'urss qui allait
assez mal sur le plan économique la
glace noces c'est la fin du goulag la
liberté de parole il appert et stryyke à
ses gardes et l'idéal socialiste mais
supprimer les déviations du stalinisme
vous dites dans votre livre on peut dire
que le communisme total a subi une
défaite totale est ce que cette idée que
le communisme total étaient mauvais pour
la russie vous l'aviez depuis longtemps
ou est ce que vous l'avez réaliser quand
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
comme ici ce qui au départ je fais des
communes et j'y croyais et je croyais
compost plus en terminale j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste quand j'étais en
terminale
et je suis resté du parti pendant les
onze années
et c'est quand j'étais au parc moi j'ai
commencé à faire de la politique et
musique déjà cumulé d'information
d'informations plus je comprenais que ce
système ne fonctionne pas il le modèle
est mauvais
cela dit j'avais quand même désillusion
je pensais que j'arriverai amélioré
et j'ai passé mes deux premières années
et noir et quoi cela dit le modèle était
toujours là il était toujours aussi
riche que j'ai compris qu'il fallait le
remplacer ce n'est pas l'idée socialiste
qui est bénéfique m adel c'est
par ici du communisme qui est imposé par
les bolchéviques à la russie qui par un
échec cuisant c'est comme ça que la
paire historique a devancé au voisin
déjà 13 points s'était 1988 alors à
l'époque vous voulez en revenir à ce que
disait le jeune marx quand ils n'étaient
pas encore partisans de la dictature du
prolétariat
bref vous voulez revenir à ce qu'on
appelle communisme à visage humain
c'est-à-dire le socialisme mais vous
aviez ouvert la boîte de pandore
et une fois que vous avez donné quelques
libertés aux gens la glace noces de la
pérestroïka
l'urss implose et vous en perdez le
contrôle
un petit peu comme en france louis saez
quand il a accepté la convocation des
états généraux et que la situation lui a
échappé est ce qu'aujourd'hui on ne vous
félicite pas pour quelque chose
non pas que vous avez fait mais que vous
n'avez pas pu empêcher et moi je me suis
aurait très bien pu ne rien faire sur
cugnaux bourgogne rattachés à ce moment
là j'aurais été secrétaire général du pc
est ce à ce jour les choses
mais quand je suis monté au sommet dans
le tarn du pouvoir hier quand je suis
venu
ce qui était une énorme puissance à
isoler de leurs âmes des martyrs qui
avait une seule younis nodal on approuve
les nectars au pouvoir eh bien j'ai
commencé à démarcher pouvoir m'a craché
comment se rendre à le croire au peuple
ils s'étaient sert mieux aider la
démocratie l'ouverture et la liberté
cela fait bouger la russie tout d'abord
il y avait un monde
ensuite je faisais nos pays faisait
entre les doigts
et on peut dire que j'ai laissé agir
l'histoire alors là effectivement à ce
moment là c'est le démantèlement du
rideau de fer entre la hongrie et
l'autriche
la chute du mur de berlin la
réunification de l'allemagne la
disparition du pacte de varsovie et en
1991 la chute de l'urss alors 1991 c'est
l'année du putsch l'ailé dure du parti
communiste d'union soviétique
profite du fait que vous êtes en
vacances en crimée et le 19 août 91 à
7h20 du matin l'agent stas annonce que
vous êtes incapable d'assumer vos
fonctions pour raisons de santé
vous êtes remplacé par le vice président
qui s'appelle ianaïev l'état d'urgence
est déclaré les chats entre dans moscou
et boris elstine appel désobéissance
civile à la grève générale à ce moment
là françois mitterrand qui était
président de la république en france
tout de suite ce rallye aliens et f vous
en pensez quoi de ce ralliement subi qui
étaient considérés ici en france comme
une faute politique de casse du maillage
store président yann moreau et bien je
pense que fond celui de voir le
président milliards mon ami
qui est resté mon ami jusqu'à la fin
je pense qu'à l'époque simplement ils ne
maîtrisaient pas l'ensemble des
informations en ligne des stagiaires ce
qui s'est passé en réalité progaming et
remercié tout comme les autres leaders
politiques chinois si tous cas me rend
triste à voir l'immense majorité de la
population russe
il a protesté
il a même envoyé son messager un
représentant de l'ambassade de france à
moscou qui est venu me voir en crimée à
foros voulu ans n'avait jamais voulu
d'avoir rallié aussi rapidement et nf
non non non non jamais switch la ville
il ya deux mois j'étais présidente
le présidient aux postures pharma c'est
ce que j'essaye simplement match au
président a eu des informations
et on sait qu'ils n'étaient pas vraies
il pensait qu'à ce jeu démocratie animal
le président tombe gravement malade
c'est l'ex président qui prend le
pouvoir c'est vrai qu'il a compris que
ce n'était pas le cas il a tout de suite
il reconnu et là donc c'est un petit peu
la russie contre l'urss
les putschistes sont arrêtés
boris elstine suspens le parti
communiste d'union soviétique le
parlement acquiesce vous démissionnez et
l'urss n'existe plus alors les
observateurs ont dit gorbatchev que ce
putsch avait été en fête organisée par
vous pour rétablir l'état d'urgence et
la censure sans ternir votre image
nos primes a été shootée absolue et bien
vous comprenez j'espère que c'est un
règlement absurde et yasaka zamal et
entre le quai de la
gare vous voulez dire que
gym d'accord c'est vraiment combiné
québec
je venais a signé le 4 avril du droit à
bout de piste et munitions de la région
de québec rytchkov a dit demain ce sera
trop tard le traité l'union aurait pas
fini ce sera trop tard fois j'en utilise
le jour le 19 ou des pressions que je
devais lui ces gens là qu il faudrait
qu'à partir du moment où le nouveau
traité de l'union sera signé a plongé ce
serait fini pour eux alors on a dit ça
on a dit aussi que ce putsch était une
tentative des conservateurs c'est à dire
des durs du parti communiste d'union
soviétique pour vous forcer à choisir le
camp des durs vous étiez hésitant ça y
est plus très bien quoi faire et que ce
putsch était une façon de vous obliger à
prendre le parti des conservateurs vous
répondez quoi à ça
et à ce que je n'acheterai et bien cela
je veux vous dire que ce sont des
bobards animal et ada les jo c'est parce
que ces gens là ne vais pas me combattre
ouvertement jeu tony dire arriver au
bronze ils ont payé pour cela qu'ils ont
compris qu'ils allaient absolue leur
seul espoir international d'origine dont
il est actionnaire
le reste ce sont des inventions alors
ensuite c'était la chute de l'urss la
chute des pays de l'est
il n'y a jamais eu en urss de procès de
nuremberg comme il ya eu à la chute de
l'allemagne nazie pour juger les crimes
du stalinisme
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas que
cela n'ait pas été fait
et
puis se mettre un point d'égalité entre
le stalinisme de fascisme et moi ce
n'est pas la même chose
l'union soviétique dirigée par staline
d'ailleurs
combattu le fascisme
pourquoi les chiens avec d'autres pays
bien entendu vous ne croyez pas que
mourir au goulag c'est comme mourir à
auschwitz
et à fiorano pour moi ce sont deux
histoires différentes que même mon amie
annie prie aime l'énergie
cela dit
impressionné le stalinisme passe
monétaire au canada s'est
imposée s'est arrêté avec le goulag
plaisir
de masse c'est grâce à cela le pays a
été réalisée oui c'est vrai qu'il a eu
beaucoup d'acquis mais est ce que le jeu
en valait la peine
on a payé pour cela avec un son d'une
imagerie notion yade à l'ordre c'est
khrouchtchev qui a commencé à critiquer
il est monté ce système et c'est moi qui
achevait ce travail quelle faute
reconnaissez vous
il fallait commencer par réformer le
parti communiste
poker le parti communiste de l'urss
devenue le principal frein
nous avons enregistré mai
la difficulté des problèmes des
différents ateliers qui composent et le
reste
fallait tout
reprendre
refaire le traité de l'union bien avant
et enfin la troisième fois que les sacs
retina 17 sept
il aurait fallu rappeler mon avc une
dérisoire à l'ignorer militaire de 10 à
15% tout de suite pour acheter à manger
pour les populations c'est au moment où
le genre
attendre pendant des heures dans les
files d'attenté le disque dispose c'est
là que les gens ont dit à quelque chose
qui cloche avec gorbatchev est ce que le
fait par exemple d'avoir minimisé
l'importance de la catastrophe de
tchernobyl n'a pas été une erreur que
vous reconnaissez aujourd'hui
winnie en prime time à stable nous on
n'a rien signé du tout sa rude à gauche
ici une commission d'experts c'était les
meilleurs spécifique lions gate a envoyé
sur place
et même ses meilleurs experts jeu prisa
choix pendant deux jours de suite
n'arrivait pas à nous dire ce qui s'est
passé parce que daniel il n'y comprenez
rien toile castard les biens sociaux
n'avaient rien à dire au monde mais dès
qu'on a appris l'information au
l'annoncé tout de suite est-ce que l'
aventure en afghanistan n'a pas été une
erreur hasek si ça a été une erreur
monnier pour la chanteuse a fait
l'historique et mais
je vous rappelle que les leaders de la
peyrie ce truc moi le premier on a
retiré les troupes temps accepter une
décision difficile croyez moi
aujourd'hui vous les américains s'en
sortent mieux que l'urss en afghanistan
dans hannah n'y après dima je pense que
c'était quelque chose d'indispensable
il fallait la faire
il fallait le faire et la rigueur ce
pays c'est trop
centre d'information de théories salib
régime taliban
ont refusé de céder aux injonctions du
conseil de sécurité dans ses attendus
ils ont refusé de collaborer avec les
états unis ce pays doit y être fin à
cette situation la seule solution qui
adore inscrit à rester c'était la
solution et
non celui
ci hydrogène et cette situation tend à
l'après du président d'un des vertiges
de tapas un
moyeu leur dire que c'est aux
quatre coins
de l'île étant casterns suffit d'envoyer
des
missiles ribbon bits c'est une chatte
par antolin contre le terrorisme ne peut
pas adopter les méthodes terroristes
quel sentiment avez vous quand vous
voyez la russie d'aujourd'hui la
criminalité la corruption
est ce que vous vous sentez pas un peu
responsable de ça quand vous voyez
l'espérance de vie en baisse
est ce que finalement c'est terrible à
dire mais ce que finalement les gens
vivaient pas mieux du temps du
communisme nous dira
le père de russes à l'heure actuelle il
n'y a que des jeunes sur le pont ce qui
ont
une petite quarantaine ne veulent plus
retourner vers l'est quand on leur pose
la question tourne un pays où vous
aimeriez ils disent nous allons vivre
dans un pays libre et démocratique
et je pense que ces serres la victoire
de la paire historique
ça c'est le grand chose d'eux est bon si
chara si
la russie c'est la corrida ou accélérer
etc mais c'est très réducteur
la russie s'est aussi la nouvelle classe
le dj les entrepreneurs
ce nom c'est l'esprit d'entraidé mois ci
un refuge naturel
qui il est remonté
est-ce que vous souffrez aujourd'hui de
ne plus être à faire est ce que vous
souffrez de ne plus avoir le pouvoir
c'est de
posséder le pouvoir comme on possède une
fin où les agenais mais pour moi une
femme toujours été plus importants que
daniel et leurs chiens ici en photo mais
je ne suis je ne suis pas de ceux qui me
sont arrivées de politique et lui et lui
justement l on cherche on veut oui
il faut réfléchir autrement alors vous
avez vous avez changé parce que je
évidemment les premières fissures dans
l' empire soviétique c'était solidarnosc
en pologne lech walesa qui est un ami de
jean paul 2 et et vous dites que
l'église catholique et romaine penche à
gauche et que les encyclique du pape
critique la rapacité du capitalisme
c'est assez étonnant de voir ça c'est
aujourd'hui merengue repas de chef qui
dans son livre rend hommage à la
dimension sociale de l'église catholique
je pense que l'église catholique tout
comme l'église ait odeurs
ses églises ont toujours joué un rôle
très important toujours adopté de
position humaniste
écouter ce que dit le pape actuel
quand il parle de la fin du mondial je
sais pas l'ouvrir il dit que le lot d'un
nouvel ordre mondial est indispensable
pour ce match il doit être plus stable
plus équitable et plus humain s'est
vraiment passé magnifique
bien alors votre livre est écrit avec
daisaku ikeda
c'est quand même le chef de la soka
gakkai vous savez que la sauver à kayes
c'est une secte ultra riches et
puissantes qui a un revenu annuel de 2
milliards de dollars d actifs de 100
milliards de dollars et 11 millions
d'adeptes dans le monde 2 est ce que ça
vous gêne pas de co signer un livre avec
quelqu'un dont on connaît mal finalement
la finalité des activités
stn est fière de moi
je dit il mais non vous savez je crois
que là il ya pas mal de choses qui ont
été inventés au sujet des qui devait
céder ce livre est particulièrement en
france je ne sais pas d'où ça vient et
quels en sont les airs aux racines ce
livre a été publié dans un bon nombre de
pays déjà ce livre a été bien adoptés
par les lecteurs
c'est la première chose et or jamais on
m'a posé ce genre de questions ça
réussit maintenant monsieur liquide
heures avant moi à discuter avec une
centaine de personnalités de tous les
coûts nous
et personne n'a jamais c'est vraiment qc
et qui sait et ne lui a jamais n'a lui
jamais dit qu'il était responsable
conseil attendait ils ont tous millions
de membres avant tout les cas on peut
pas dire mikhaïl gorbatchev que vous
vous soyez enrichi au pouvoir vous au
mois votre fortune en 98 était estimée à
2,8 millions de francs que vous avez
déposé dans une banque qui a fait
faillite et vous dites aujourd'hui les
nouveaux riches russes dépenses en une
nuit ce que je gagne en une année
j'aimerais dire de la mia problème a vu
leur note credit and cook en fait à
l'heure actuelle j'ai des dettes
vis-à-vis d'eux ma banque la banque qui
m'a accordé des prêts au moment où j'ai
mis en place ma nation il faut continuer
le travail ouais mais où est passé le
million de dollars du prix nobel
non puisque premier à sochaux là et
vient en partie n'a pris 1,14 à ce cher
larissa a été dépêché pour le projet de
série 5 c'était un centre de lutte
contre la leucémie
et sony le reste
j'ai fait construire d'aujourd'hui cela
dans la région de la ministre bref ça a
été trop penser à des fins gardant
milquet et aux éditions de dollars et
voilà ce que j'ai été obligé de faire
pour gagner votre vie magnéto serge
[Musique]
quant à gorbatchev
maintenant
[Musique]
mon
niveau
[Musique]
ça n'a pas trop macho
[Applaudissements]
alors
pourquoi faire une publicité pour pizza
hut quand on était le chef de l'ue à 16h
tout dire cynique richert funds comment
voulez vous que je les fasse sur abc
news nous avons nous avons le bâtiment
de demain font déjà dit rien
après la crise financière il signe nous
a retiré la table ce bâtiment et c'est à
cette époque là que j'étais obligé de
férocité nas ou simplement pour assurer
le quotidien mais nous avons été sauvés
par jane fonda et ted turner françois a
voulu poser une question on en dire une
seule chose parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont là dans le
public les simplement dire que quand les
enfants de vos enfants étudieront
l'histoire du siècle y aura une page sur
cet homme là et que ça méritait qu'on le
dise et la justice voudrait qu'il y ait
aussi un bout de pages pour sa femme
raïssa
là
alors maintenant mais rigueur batshia
vous allez être soumis à une interview
un petit peu spécial ça s'appelle la
review et on ne bouge pas pour le jingle
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pensez à quoi la rochelle contact
je pense que le contact a été bon vous
avez raison
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
richesse à l'enterrement de ma femme
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
bonjour ya brillé une fois ce projet je
ne l'aurais pas utiliser cette baguette
magique ya secret dieci récompense
taurine des
communes si vous voulez aider quelqu'un
ne faut pas lui donner du poisson il
faut les apprendre comment pêcher
[Applaudissements]
si notre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi dans cette vie
dont je suis naïve à yabuli mignard eh
bien je n'aurais peut-être pas changer
ma vie car en fait je suis content de
mon surf isbn extrait you moi je viens
d'une famille pauvre desprès gessien
province alors je viens d'un pays
province profonde et je suis monté au
sommet quand même quelque chose
contre si j'avais à refaire la paire
historique un
tir je leur ai fait le même choix
j'arrête toujours choisi la liberté la
démocratie la snes l'ouverture
demain j'aurais changé quelque peu mes
priorités
ça c'est sûr je reconnais mes erreurs et
je pense que la pérestroïka aurait
continué à ce moment là imaginons que l
époque au début du siècle dernier le
tsar nicolas ii n'ait pas été renversées
et que la russie se soient modernisés
mais en restant dans le monde occidental
et sous le régime du tsar peut-être une
façon plus constitutionnel est ce
qu'aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle en
2001 est-ce que vous pensez que la
russie serait plus en avance ou moins en
avance est-ce que vous pensez que la
révolution soviétique a fait progresser
globalement globalement positif comme
disait georges marchais et fils
responsable du parti communiste français
est ce que pensait que l'expérience a
été globalement positive ou globalement
négative
des dégâts
sérieux
ça me fait penser une histoire il ya une
délégation français au prix vient en
visite officielle en chine
ils sont accueillis par twin l'eau et
les vias et lui pose la question
suivante kg
que pensez-vous de l'aviron sera de la
révolution française sur le monde et sur
la chine 4 et bien le premier ministre
chinois de l'époque
a répondu ceci parce que richard à la
peau noire et étonne t il est encore
trop tôt pour tirer des conclusions
définitives mais tient bon le cap ce que
les mario saint charles après comment
vivez vous faire le bilan de la
révolution d'octobre comment
aimeriez-vous mourir
on ne reviendra c'est dieu qui décidera
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
9 les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus